of all the different scripts that you
have and like this bin
yeah i don't know if it's a real binge
oh it's real wow okay that was a
metaphor
i like to have tactile papers so yes
it's a real bed of scripts
okay um have there been any that
you want to make but the budget isn't
there and it wouldn't
do it justice to do it on a an indie
budget
yes there's like three that have floated
to the top of that that um i'd very much
like
to do um the process of working that
would involve
some other people to make that work one
is a
science fiction uh kind of apocalyptic
creature movie
uh one of them is a very intense
psychological horror movie
uh with the female protagonist uh or
slash antagonist depending on how you
look at it uh but then another one i
um that i really wanted to do was um
a comedy horror creature uh
film which i really was really
tried really hard to like crunch numbers
to figure out like how could we
creatively do it
but it still was too much but we
actually came up with a creative way of
telling that story
in a different medium so
low laurence came up the idea i'd say
well like
i want to do like maybe i could adapt
the script
into like a fun fun text
and then we could have a picture every
three or four pages to make it visual
and keep it fun
uh and then uh and then she came up with
the idea of like well no no it should be
like a
we should do a picture per per page of
text so like every
page you have text and then you have a
cool picture on the other side and i'm
like oh that's great
so it was a way of us keeping the visual
nature of it
um be able to tell
to still have images uh while also being
able to do
uh you know have the text and tell the
story yet not be
limited uh by the budget of like if you
were trying to tell it into a movie and
that's
this is an early prototype book of it
called innards
um which it's very early prototype uh we
have
uh amazing artist armando norte
who did the illustrations for it so
there's 106 illustrations
for the novella so like once again a
picture for every every
every page uh low is actually doing the
coloring in in a weird way the lighting
on the black and white illustrations
and she also just came up with the other
day it's really exciting she just came
up with the idea
because we were trying to figure out how
to make the text work with the image and
keep it visual as well
and she came up with the great idea that
the text is actually going to be hand
printed as well
to go along so the text even though it's
on the right side and it's text it's
going to be hand written and hand drawn
and it's very creative in terms of like
how the
uh how the text is done and that was
always even when it was typed it was
done that way
so like in terms of the words that come
out and the layout and the page and
stuff it's very different
so it's a really unique i'm really
excited about it because it's very
unique
because we call it an illustrated
novella it's not a comic book
but it's definitely not a novella with a
few illustrations so
it's living in this interesting
in-between world between the two
so it's very unique uh but it really it
just suited the story really well
because it was a comedy story
uh the comedy comes from the characters
and the very bizarre situation
uh so with the creature so because it
was comedy just really lend itself
to doing it with this fun text style
with the uh
with the images and a very uh
interesting graphic images to go with it
it really lended itself to be able to
tell it in this way so
that's something we're going to turn to
after echoes of fear our last feature
comes out
uh fall of 2019 hopefully everything
works out on that
we're going to start turning our
attention to that low's currently
finishing the coloring and lighting on
it
so yeah so that's that's innards so how
long
how long was the script oh the script
was a full feature script
um trying to remember like how many
script pages i think it was like 98
script pages okay uh but you know of
course it's it's not the script
i i had to like go back to my creative
writing
origins and and you know convert the
script into a story
but the great thing was because of the
illustrations
i could keep the story really simple and
fun in terms of this text part because
the
the illustration of page kind of gives
you a lot of the details that you would
have to do
if you were just writing the story you'd
have well what does the main character
look like you have to describe it you
describe the creature really well and
the location so
basically by having the image of page it
enables you to kind of get more into the
meat and the fun of the story in terms
of the dialogue
in the key events in action you can kind
of jump right to that in the text
because the picture is kind of helping
you along
helping the the reader or viewer
along in terms of what what it looks
like visually so that's why it's a fun
really fun marriage and that's where it
comes in a little bit heading into your
comic book realm
a little bit uh but a lot more text in a
comic book where it comes back into
novella
world so it's in that nice in-between
space that we kind of created
we know adaptations are common but how
common is it for a script
to then be turned into a novella or a
novel
whatever you know i think it happens
from time to time a lot of times it
happens because people will do it
um to try to sell the script uh in the
story
which i of course would not be against
if that ended up happening
once they illustrated uh you know energy
illustrated novella came out if it
helped it turned into a movie great
but our key goal was in doing it to make
it a very like
its own project so if it doesn't if it
leaves the movie
great if it doesn't lead to a movie it's
okay because
it exists in this in its own way
you know in this form that people can
enjoy it and get the story
and once again a way of someone
experiencing the story
uh that you can't get you can't like
hand someone a script
you know it's like it's like handing
someone who's not an architect the
blueprints of a house
it's not a very satisfying way to
experience a story you know scripts
aren't meant
to be the end result i mean scripts are
always a step like the burpees of a
house to turn into a house to turn into
a movie
so to so this was fun with this is this
basically
you know adapting it in such a way that
it's complete
in above itself that's really cool it's
very exciting we'll get it done this
year for sure and then we'll figure out
uh like how to get it out there that'll
be a whole new distribution world
because we've never done it we've never
done distribution of the books
so i don't know is this so you don't
know so you we have to learn
because it's first time we've ever done
this i mean i mean our all of our
experience from doing
um movies doesn't really lend itself
to what we're going to do with this
novella so that'll be something new
we'll have to learn in terms of
distribution and marketing and and you
know what the best way is for
to get it out there to people where did
you actually get the book made
uh it's a beautiful book you want to
hold it up oh yeah absolutely gorgeous
um where did you actually get the once
you had the artist attached and you were
finished with your text
where did you actually get it put
together the book the bounding
well this this is just the prototype of
it uh we wanted to do it
uh lo found a place to have it printed
uh so we could basically have a proof of
concept for ourselves
because uh this was early on before the
text was was handwritten so the text is
just typed
but we just wanted to get a sense and
the images are still black and white
and a lot of them weren't in their
complete stage yet but we just wanted to
get
a sense of like well how would it work
in terms of reading it and experiencing
it
getting your image per page you know and
so how would that feel and how would it
work
and so it was kind of like a proof of
concept for us to be able to hold it in
our hands
and read it and uh you know we made a
lot of changes from this because this
was a great way of us kind of like it's
almost like
a rough draft or a first cut of a movie
is a great way to kind of get a layout
of like oh okay
so this is where it's heading and how
can we make it better
and from this we realized that like to
really make it pop
and for the comedy to come through it
was it was important to do the color
and then low actually experimented and
learned how to
do the coloring on it and she's a dp so
it's weird it's like you actually add
lighting once you add color
so in an interesting way you're almost
like adding color and lighting it
and it helped bring out uh the artist of
mondo norde
and it helped really bring his
illustrations out you could really see
the line work he did and everything it
helped like
it helped the viewer be able to see that
better and like see all that detail work
they did on it
and uh and like i said in just uh
recently we we learned from doing all
that that she came up with the idea of
doing the text
in a hand-drawn manner to once again
helping with the comedy and the flow of
it
and and complementing the illustrations
so we're very excited how it's going to
turn out
it'd be interesting imagine like it's
such a hit that they want a second one
but they don't want to turn into a movie
they actually like it
in novella form and it becomes like its
own series that's great cool i mean we
every time we do a creative project
we're like we try not to think about
what it's gonna
who knows what's gonna lead to so we try
to be open you know we like finish it
and see where it goes and see what
opportunities it opens up
for whether it's a movie what
opportunity it opens up for another
movie
if it's this you know if it opens up an
opportunity to tell another story this
way i mean it'd be interesting
so i think for us it's like finding the
right avenue
um to tell the story you know what it
lends itself to
you know to tell it did you go to
bookstores the few that are left and and
try to see i mean
sorry the few wonderful book stores that
are left did you go to them and try to
see what other novellas
in the horror section just to get an
idea since this was a new realm
well yes we actually dropped into a
amazing
um horror shop called dark delicacies
uh and they are burbank sorry uh yes
okay yes
yes uh and um it was interesting because
the proprietor that dell he uh is an
author
himself and he's very aware of
everything that's out there in
publishing especially in the horror
genre realm and it basically there
wasn't there
it's kind of unique there isn't anything
exactly like this
there's some things with an image
um but um it's like every three or four
pages
or it's not balanced the same we did see
like a book that was done there i can't
remember the name of it
later after we kind of done the
prototype and and mapped it out where
they did kind of have an image
and and with text per page but it was
different it was
it wasn't a novella as much it was
almost like poetry in a way so
so it's like we haven't really seen
anything exactly like this which to us
is exciting
we've heard other people say well that's
not good because it doesn't fall into
like a little niche
like oh it's that type it's this it's
that
but to me it's exciting is different
remember shel silverstein
like to his thing you know remember shel
silverstein the writer like
oh okay he did kind of like these cool
like poems and
then there would be these drawings and i
mean i'm dating myself i think that's
like a bay area
no i mean he was worldwide i know but so
he kind of
i don't know when i was a kid like the
poet the poet that really impressed me
uh in terms of what he did visually was
e cummings
and how he laid out his uh poetry
actually
uh really affected me a lot i actually
you know a long time ago did some poetry
and i would kind of like it was a
i kind of fell into a similar thing
where i would visually kind of move the
words around in a different creative way
which when it got adapted into this
novella that same thing kind of came
through
even though i hadn't done it since i
don't know college i guess
but but the same thing would happen
where like i would bring words up and
words would be big and move things on
the page different
and uh so that's why it's like it's
different even in the text side of it
it's not just like a
normal text where it's like line nine
nine nine nine line paragraph
you know it has its own uh its own uh
rhythm and style in terms of that as
well which will be brought out even more
that's going to be the text now the text
is going to be done by hand by low it's
going to
make that even more pronounced so i'm
very excited were you you were a poet in
tennessee
in high school that was good
how was that pretentiously awful
i i didn't have any like-minded people i
filled books
with my poetry uh
which no one has ever no one has ever
seen them except for
uh very good friends and and laurence
obviously lois has seen
has seen some of them but uh but yeah it
was just for me
uh it was it was a way i would let out
creative outlet
uh steam when i couldn't make a movie i
would use that as an outlet
that's before i became i would write
scripts so much once i started writing
scripts a lot more
i kind of like kind of stopped doing
that and became much more just writing
scripts with an outlet
now because of this i'm kind of it's
weird i'm dovetailing back into that a
little bit but
but for me it's like the key is whatever
we do i just want it to be entertaining
because it's like i do this even though
it
it's very personal and it's stories
we're interested in
to me it's like it's also stories that
should interest other people because
it's done for other people to see and
have fun with
uh even when we do the scary
supernatural horror movies they're
it's fun you know it's scary i mean it's
good to have a it's fun to have a good
scare
and tell a creepy scary suspense horror
story so
everything we do is kind of like focus
on it being entertaining
which is why i get scared to say the
word poetry that's why that poetry does
not exist in little books i hand out
it's just for me
uh because i don't i don't think it
would those things would be really
entertaining
for someone else it's more like
something i would do creatively but it's
not something designed
for the outside world because i don't
think other people would find it
[Laughter]
entertaining
you